寫過《國家為什麼會失敗》的 MIT 經濟學家 Daron Acemoglu
2024 年拿下諾貝爾經濟學獎
這幾年他研究的是 AI 會讓誰受益
誰被丟下
今年 9 月底
MIT 替他的新書辦了一場座談
書名問的是：自由民主到底怎麼了
主持這場對談的是 Michael Sandel
哈佛政治哲學教授
他的《正義》是哈佛第一門免費放上網的課
全世界幾千萬人看過
中文書名叫《正義：一場思辨之旅》
經濟學家跟哲學家坐在一起
談的是一個老問題：新技術帶來的好處
為什麼沒分到大多數人手上
AI 會不會再來一次
兩個人同意的地方不少
只是走到結論的路不一樣
前半小時談美國政治的部分先跳過
這集從 Sandel 質問經濟學家的那一段開始
Sandel 先替經濟學家把話講完
新技術跟自由貿易會有贏家
也會有輸家，但贏家賺到的
多到足夠補償輸家
新自由主義全球化那時候，這套話我們聽了一遍又一遍，
現在講 AI，我們又聽到同一套
那些經濟學家是不是漏了什麼？
我們認罪。是的
我不是說你當年也是啦啦隊，
但他們到底漏了什麼？
我覺得首先，這裡有兩套不同的說法，
也許不只兩套，
你剛剛其實兩套都點到了，
它們在經濟學家的推論裡扮演的角色不太一樣，
在政治經濟裡也是
第一套，我覺得今天在討論 AI 的時候也還是非常主流，
就是認為任何技術進步，
只要提高了我們生產商品跟服務的能力，
用經濟學家的行話，就是把技術可能性的邊界往外推，
最後都會讓每個人受益
也許會有短暫的挫折，有些人丟了工作，
但生產力提高了，就會有更多工作、更高的薪水，
不管做什麼，
就算一開始受益的是資本家、工程師，或一小群人，
最後都會滴下來
滴漏論有好幾種版本，
但本質上是同一回事
這正是我跟 Simon Johnson
在上一本書《權力與進步》裡，核心要反駁的說法
不知道我們影響了多少，但我們試過了，
我跟 David Autor、Pascual Restrepo 做的很多研究，
也是在學術上做同樣的事
第二套說法是，會有一些永遠的輸家，
尤其當你承認每個人的技能不一樣，比如在全球化的脈絡裡，
但，這就是你剛講的那個，
收益總是比損失大，
而且會有某種機制去補償輸家
問題是，從來沒有
那是在政治經濟裡決定的
你經濟上變好了，政治上也會更有力量
那你通常就不會去做那些重分配，
而且我們常常連完美的工具都沒有
David Autor 對「中國衝擊」的研究，就把這點講得非常清楚
對，我覺得那些研究很重要
你跟你的同事做的研究，是一個很難得的異端替代方案，
至少從經濟學圈外看起來，
主流並不是這樣看事情的
在這套說法裡，
主流經濟學家，至少很多人，似乎忽略了一點：
贏家的收益，並沒有變成有效的重分配
而重分配能不能取代共享的繁榮，
又是另一個問題了
Acemoglu 的答案最後落在政治
錢分不下去，是因為贏家也拿到了權力
Sandel 想問的是再下一步
就算錢真的分下去，夠不夠
幾分鐘後他回到這題
先把不平等拆成兩種
所以可以這樣說：
新自由主義全球化的經濟安排，
拉大了貧富差距
這是經濟上的不平等
但同一時間，
贏家跟輸家之間的鴻溝也在加深，
而這跟貧富差距是兩回事
沒錯
贏家跟輸家。
這一部分跟經濟不平等擴大有關，
但也跟贏家的一種傾向有關：
他們相信成功是自己掙來的，
所以成功就是他們配得上的證明
言下之意，被拋下的人也是活該
我一開始籠統地說過，Michael 的研究對我影響很大，
從他剛剛這段話，就看得到我從他那裡學到最多的三件事
第一是社群的角色，來自你比較早的著作
另外兩件跟今天的討論很有關，
特別是來自《成功的反思》
一是用「功績」去解讀成功跟失敗，
會變成一股羞辱過得沒那麼好的人的力量
第三個，是它很漂亮地
講出了很多我一直想不清楚的想法，
就是「貢獻正義」這個概念：
光是重分配、讓人有足夠的東西可以消費，是不夠的
人還需要感覺到自己在為社會做貢獻，
這關係到他們怎麼看待自己的貢獻，
也關係到別人的肯定
這些都跟今天談的有關
接下來他換回經濟學家的講法
拿歷史跟數字說同一件事
這不只是重分配的問題，
我可以從兩方面再強調
第一，不管是近代還是更早的歷史，
我找不到任何一個持久的共享繁榮，不是建立在薪資成長上的
所以薪資成長絕對必要，不只是為了共享繁榮，
也是為了讓這份繁榮對人有意義
第二，我認為極端形式的重分配，傷害會很大，
就像你剛講的那樣
用全民基本收入來想，最容易懂
如果我們得靠全民基本收入，去養活比如 50%、60%、70% 的人口，
這些人在 AI 時代找不到工作，
或找不到收入夠好的工作，撐起越來越高的期待，
那會是一個讓人很喪氣的經濟，
一大部分的人會覺得、也會被告知：
你只是靠那些很有創意的工程師、企業領袖、CEO 掉下來的碎屑活著
我覺得那是災難的配方
我覺得這點非常非常重要
他說還不必走到那一步
他跟兩位 MIT 同事提過一個方向
叫「對勞工友善的 AI」，讓水電工
護理師
老師靠 AI 做到以前做不到的事
Sandel 下面說的「你們三位」
指的就是這三個人
對。我覺得你們三位強調的這件事很重要，
共享的繁榮，
靠的不只是全民基本收入買得到的基本物資
它需要你真的是參與者，
有聲音、有發言權，
去形塑那些支配我們生活的力量，
包括經濟跟職場長什麼樣子
你們強調對勞工友善的 AI，這些研究我覺得之所以重要，
是它教我們：AI 的目標、
AI 的目的，
不能是取代工作，而是強化工作，
讓勞工的生產力提高，薪水也跟著提高
你剛提到的貢獻正義，就在這背後
它點出的，是只講分配正義會漏掉的東西：
人最根本的需要，
在基本消費品跟生活必需品之外，
最根本的需要，是被我們的同胞需要，
能夠用我們的努力跟才能去回應那些需要，
並因此贏得社會的尊重、
榮譽跟認可
這是貢獻正義的要求，
全民基本收入給不了這個
這才是讓繁榮真正被共享的東西
共享的不只是錢。是活動，是共同的生活
是那個共同的計畫
計畫，包括用民主審議去決定這個計畫長什麼樣
Acemoglu 接著講回 AI
業界每天說 AI 會改變你生活的每一個面向
同時又叫你別擋路
交給專家跟幾家前沿實驗室就好
他說在民主社會，這兩句話再矛盾不過
對，Daron，這點我同意
他們說我們只剩幾分鐘就要開放提問了
但在那之前，我忍不住想問，
如果等一下有 AI 的問題，你可以再多講：
最近那一波末日論，
說人類十年內有滅絕的風險
為什麼，我本來希望今天來能從你這裡學到，為什麼
別太樂觀
我直覺上對那些說法很提防，
不是因為我是技術專家，
知道他們把風險跟滅絕機率算錯了，
而是因為它聽起來詭異地、矛盾地自利
當這些實驗室的領導者跟參與者向我們宣告：
我們手上這東西強大到可能毀滅人類，
大家最好擔心一下
為什麼我覺得這很可疑？
嗯，我的看法是，我沒有什麼讀心的特殊能力，
看不透那些發表這些說法的高層跟中層在想什麼，
但我認為他們是真心的，他們是真的在擔心這些事
但這也凸顯了，如果你看他們的背景，
在這件事上，讓出身非常狹窄的一群人掌權，為什麼會有問題
Anthropic 的整個高層，還有 OpenAI、DeepMind 的很多人，
都來自同一個圈子，對 AI 的看法都一樣
吞下的是同一批科幻小說
讀的是同一批網路哲學家
好，那你講到的就是意識形態了
我跟 Simon 在《權力與進步》裡強調過一個很重要的觀點：
意識形態一直在左右技術的方向，
而在 AI 這件事上更是如此
開放提問之後，台下有人問
在大科技公司裡
要怎麼真的把 AI 往對勞工友善的方向做
Sandel 是這樣回答的
至於 AI 的問題，
怎麼把它導向對勞工友善的用途，
關於 AI 的治理，公共辯論才剛開始，
也就是最近幾個月的事
我懷疑光設一個監管機構是不夠的，
因為那等於接受現有的結構，
只是讓政府的監管者從外面盯著
要讓大眾對 AI 的方向有發言權，
一個辦法是讓大眾持有這些公司的股份，
不管是公共投資、公有，
還是部分公有
這麼主張是有道理的，
因為它們賴以運作、賴以生財的那些海量資料，
那些餵進它們正在蓋的、嗡嗡運轉的資料中心的資料，
那到底是誰的資料？不是他們的
現在有一些個別著作權人的官司
但在著作權官司之外，
有一個更大的問題：
這些資料實質上是不是像一種自然資源、公共資源，
如果是，那治理制度就應該
讓大眾對這個資源怎麼用有發言權
講到發錢夠不夠
經濟學家跟哲學家從兩條路走到同一個答案
不夠，人要有事做，也要被需要
兩個人看法不同的只有末日論
Sandel 覺得那聽起來很自利
Acemoglu 則相信他們是真心的
只是整群人讀的是同一批書
原影片一個多小時
問答時間 Acemoglu 還講到
這幾年大科技公司的決策權一直往最高層集中
中層工程師幾年前還有的影響力
現在沒了
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。